Europe has mechanisms to deal with cases
of delinquency and that means more than
just idle threats and reprimands should
an EU country go against the principles
of democracy then Europe has no choice
but to nail its colours to the mast
article seven can be triggered by the
European Commission only in the case of
a persistent and serious breach of the
rule of law it's the most radical form
of sanctions within the European Union
and has not been applied so far every au
country must uphold basic values
including freedom human dignity and the
rule of law breaches can incur real
punishment but imposing sanctions is no
simple process every single member state
has to get the approval the European
Commission needs the unanimity of the
Member States in order to trigger a tick
assemble the sanctions can be tough they
can include the suspension of voting
rights but if even one EU country is
against imposing sanctions then article
7 amounts to nothing more than empty
posturing